et la tête enrico comment ça va la 4g
des pertes de mémoire dès qu'ils
essuient l'alzheimer je sais pas qui
c'est on va faire un alzheimer est
justement l rico je vais vous dire les
titres de chansons et puis vous allez me
dire si vous avez chanté ou pas hein on
va voir attention que cela beaucoup
quand même à vous avez écrit beaucoup de
chansons 1
allons-y adieu mon pays oui salut ma
couille
oui avant deux femmes à dublin oui deux
[ __ ] à pigalle oui dix mois ce qui va
pas oui enfants de tous pays
ouais slip de toutes les couleurs je
n'ai jamais gérer jusqu en auvergne oui
j'irai jusqu'à roubaix mais je vois
partir et tout de suite ça me rappelle
que je sais l'accordéon dans les rues de
paris
oui la femme de mon ami oui la femme de
mon ami est devenue la mienne aa pour
toi mabrouk
malheur à celui qui blesse un enfant oui
malheur à celui qui touchait mercedes
alala le monde jean de l'amour même bien
sûr le clochard du sexe ou moi la porte
oui ouvre-moi laporte us se défend ce
connard ah oui un berger est tombé oui
un berger est tombé veut dire que ça
glisse rythme présente paris tu m'as
pris dans tes bras
oui paris paris je t'encule
commercial on te sens mieux c'est de la
vie populaire sont séchées
je devrai
ennuyeux
mes pensées